[shoggoth growling]
This is a shoggoth from
HBO's "Lovecraft Country."
But on set, it was a different story.
Believe it or not, these
puppet heads and arms
made the monster scarier on
screen, but that's not all.
From keeping the monster's mouth open
to treating its anatomy like a weapon
to what kind of prosthetic head
the stand-ins would hold up on set,
there were a lot of choices the
"Lovecraft" team had to make
to make sure the show's scariest
monsters terrified viewers.
Warning: Spoilers ahead
for "Lovecraft Country."
When HP Lovecraft wrote
about the shoggoths
in "At the Mountains of Madness,"
he called them "indescribable."
Not much to go off of.
So the "Lovecraft" team brought in
VFX supervisor Grant Walker
and his team at Framestore
to make the indescribable
into something tangibly scary.
The VFX team worked off sketches,
references, and concept art of the monster
created by Framestore's art department.
When Grant received the concept art,
many prominent features of the shoggoths
were already established.
For instance, that they had four limbs
as well as these tiny T. rex-like arms.
They did early animation tests
in a step called previsualization
to see how the monsters would
look and move in scenes.
Framestore's animators couldn't really get
into the CGI nitty-gritty
until they had an idea
of what the shoggoths would
look like in the scenes.
And they could do that thanks
to these stunt performers.
Stand-ins are necessary for
both the actors and animators,
allowing something
terrifying to be on camera
that isn't actually there yet.
They give the cast something to react to,
whether they're being eaten alive
or just screaming their heads off.
By leaping off a ledge
and wrapping his arms
under this cop's armpits,
this stand-in can show Framestore
where to place the shoggoth's sharp arms
that pierce straight
through the actor's chest.
But it's not so easy to be
convincingly scary on set,
especially with these big
googly eyes and missing teeth.
Grant Walker: When the actors
first saw the shoggoth,
I think they got all their
laughing out of their system
so that they could perform on set.
Narrator: And the stand-ins
make Framestore's job
much easier by identifying
characteristics like shadows,
which make them seem more realistic.
And it is important to be
as precise as possible.
In this shot, where a shoggoth
stands on its hind legs
in front of Tic and Leti, this stuntperson
had to hold this prosthetic
head about nine feet high,
which is the height of the black shoggoth
as estimated by Grant.
Given the shoggoth's strength and speed,
even the best stuntperson can't
imitate every single move,
but they do help track the exact timing
and space of where the monster would be,
allowing for a better and
scarier CGI performance.
Plus, the actors will be
looking directly into its face,
as opposed to accidentally
looking up into the sky.
Grant had many choices
for how to represent
the monster's massive size on set.
First, he and the crew tried to stack
two stand-ins on top of each other,
but they found they could more
easily cast the same shadow
by designing a prosthetic head and arms.
Grant: I took the initial
model of the shoggoth,
and I took it in its neutral pose,
and I chopped its body off.
And I left its head where it was,
and I left its arms where it was,
and I figured out how they would hold them
to hold them in the approximate
stance of a shoggoth's pose
based on all fours and
then stood up on two legs.
And so I knew that if there
was a 6-foot stunt guy,
he would hold it up here.
Narrator: Now, not every
shot had a stuntperson in it.
Sometimes the monster was just too fast
for a stuntperson to mimic.
Framestore was given both the shots
with the stand-ins and identical versions
of those shots with just the backdrop
and no reference, known as a clean plate.
Animators then had to
place the CGI shoggoths
into their scenes.
What a stand-in couldn't
communicate to Grant
was how many eyes to put on the monsters
or how sharp to make their teeth,
so it was up to Framestore
to get creative with the details.
They made the shoggoth's skin translucent,
so you can see its entire inner structure
if you shine a light on it.
Since the shoggoths live underground,
they looked to real animals
that live in the dark.
After looking at naked mole
rats and deep-sea fish,
they saw their skin tended
to be somewhat see-through.
This physical feature played into
the first episode's storyline.
When the characters shined
a light on the shoggoths,
it not only changed the appearance
of the monsters' skin,
but also repelled them.
But this presented a challenge,
as see-through skin is hard to render.
So they actually chose not
to make the skin see-through
until the compositing
process, the final element
when everything comes
together in animation.
And because the skin was see-through,
Grant had to pay extra-special attention
to its inner details, like
veins or tiny bits of jaw
that connect teeth to
the mouth and the skull.
Normally, those just
serve a practical purpose,
but here they also had to
look anatomically correct.
The shoggoths weren't
just covered in skin.
They had eyeballs everywhere.
Like the skin, all 40 eyeballs
needed to look sickly and diseased,
so they looked to the animal kingdom.
Grant: We didn't want
the eyes to be beautiful.
No one wants to look deep
into the soul of a shoggoth.
We wanted to look at horrible dark eyes,
like the black eyes of a shark.
Narrator: When designing a scary creature,
you have to make sure the scary features
still function properly.
For example, the white shoggoth
featured in the first
episode of "Lovecraft"
had black eyes.
Grant was afraid that
if they were too black,
the audience wouldn't know
where the shoggoth monsters
were looking at a given moment.
So instead of using the pupils
to see what direction it was looking in,
the audience could instead
follow the surrounding skin
and this moving layer of mucusy membrane
on top of its eye.
Being a visual effects artist
involves lots of experimentation.
This is how Framestore landed on
an important decision about the shoggoth:
keeping its mouth open
almost all the time.
Early on, Grant looked at
what one of the shoggoths
would look like with its mouth closed.
Grant: It looked like Kermit the Frog.
Narrator: Sure, Kermit is OK
for a temporary stand-in on set,
but not a terrifying finished product.
So they kept the mouth
open whenever they could.
Grant: The creature's head is 80% mouth.
Narrator: When it came to what's inside
the creature's mouth,
Grant made it scarier
by turning to some classic horror monsters
that have terrified him.
The tongue was turned
into a multipronged one
inspired by "The Thing,"
and he drew inspiration
for the sharp fangs from Pennywise
and studied animal
predators for inspiration.
Grant: We looked at sharks,
who have got many rows of teeth,
but the top jaw is not
connected to the cranium,
and a humanoid jaw is
whereas a shark's, it protrudes,
so you can actually turn the teeth out,
and it makes the really
wide-stretching jaw.
Like, the teeth start pointing
at what it's going to eat,
which is terrifying.
Narrator: The mouth was
filled with 4,000 teeth,
which is no easy feat to animate,
as CGI teeth naturally
want to start intersecting
when you put them together.
This would ruin any frightening illusion,
so Framestore used a
specific rigging method
that, according to Grant,
allowed them to nudge the teeth around
and keep them in the right place.
Part of what makes the monster so scary
is that the VFX team
turned parts of their bodies into weapons.
This decision came from
a conversation Grant had
with "Lovecraft" creator Misha Green.
Grant: Misha described it I think once
as, "It's a Swiss Army knife of weapons."
And so every limb, every point,
every part of the anatomy
has to have a purpose.
And if you don't see it use
that purpose on the screen,
it kind of gets forgotten.
Narrator: The teeth were
built for maximum bloodshed.
Originally, Grant said they
tried to make the teeth spin,
but it pushed the limits of plausibility.
Instead it was scarier
to just make the teeth
clamp down so fast that they
could liquidize a human head.
Now, remember those tiny
arms from early designs?
They were designed with sharp claws
and only really look like tiny arms
until they're used to cut
right through somebody.
You can also see in some early designs
that a shoggoth tail
looked more like a stub.
When animators extended it,
they also added a bladelike tip to it.
But it wasn't just how
the shoggoths looked
that made them so scary.
The right movement is key for making
a CGI creature truly terrifying.
The shoggoths are fast,
and Grant and his team
had the freedom to figure
out exactly how fast.
Once again, they looked
to the animal kingdom.
Grant and his team initially mimicked
the movement of gorillas,
but gorillas are slower
than what they wanted.
So they looked to the cheetah,
but that cat is too lean.
So, instead, they based
the movement off a lion,
a fast runner and a heavy predator.
Grant even matched the
shoggoth's run cycle
with a lion's average
speed of 50 miles per hour.
Even the smallest detail
didn't go overlooked.
As the shoggoths leap into action,
they also leave behind
puddles of nasty drool.
Grant: It's got a huge mouth.
We want to make it scary and disgusting.
Narrator: Because it is
so difficult to control
and there is so much of it,
drool is one of the hardest
elements to recreate in CGI.
So like hair, water, and clothes,
it needed to be simulated,
which in 3D animation just means
a computer calculated how
something, in this case drool,
would realistically behave
in certain conditions.
There also had to be
multiple types of drool
for different scenarios,
like drool running down the mouth,
drool that stuck to its teeth,
and drool that stuck on
other surfaces like the road.
And nothing says gross and scary
like drool filled with blood.
Being an animator doesn't mean
you sit behind a computer all day.
To make this complicated
shot of the black shoggoth,
Grant filmed himself
acting like the monster.
Grant: When we were figuring it all out,
we knew it was at close
proximity to the cameras.
Narrator: Grant practiced biting
and shredding a fake arm.
Then the stuntperson
replicated those moves.
Grant: And then they add their extra
flourish of performance to it.